pas de taxation des plus values sur les
actions et les obligations avant le 1er
janvier 79 proposerait montbard le
gouvernement accepte un débat à
l'assemblée nationale sur les problèmes
de la sidérurgie lorraine pour remplacer
les caravelles air france vous acheter
des boeing
tollé général dans les milieux
politiques français journée mondiale de
la vaccination demain immunisés c'est
protéger vos enfants conseil
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
vous le savez vous l'avez peut être
constaté avec nous depuis qu'il est au
pouvoir et montbard s'est efforcé de
confirmer sa détermination est bien en
tant que stratège on peut dire ce soir
qu'il n'a décidément rien à envier à
joffre il y a quelques jours dans le
plus grand secret il préparer le
remaniement ministériel
aujourd'hui ils n'ont sur la place
publique à projet qui fait déjà grand
bruit
la trop fameuse loi sur les plus values
ne sera pas appliquée avant le 1er
janvier 1979 le parlement en discutera
au mois d'octobre cela veut dire que la
partie de cette loi concernant les plus
values mobilières ne sera donc pas
applicable avant 79 retard donc dan
l'effet de surprise a été totale comme
le confirme la première page des
journaux du soir france soir une réforme
enterrait pour le journal le monde
c'est une victoire à la pyrrhus gros
titres également dans le nouveau journal
et fête surprise aussi au conseil des
ministres qui du coup a duré trois
heures
mais aussi à la bourre ch cette
vénérable institution souffrait depuis
longtemps de morosité et bien là aussi
tout enregistrer une vidéo sur ses
valeurs monsieur bart a donc frappé
juste il a coutume de dire vous savez
que pour relancer aurait dit qu'est ce
que c'est que la bourse est un marché où
on se procure
où les entreprises se procurent les
moyens financer leur développement
c'est à dire que si l'on veut que
l'emploi en france s'améliore il faut
que les entreprises puissent investir il
faut donc que les épargnants achètent
des actions des entreprises
j'ai des obligations et soit présent
apportent leur a alors ce qui a été
décidé par le gouvernement ce matin
c'est de reporter au 1er janvier 1979
l'application de la loi sur les
plus-values sur les valeurs mobilières
sur justement c'est bien qu'ils sont
échangés à la bourse
ceci afin de mettre à profit ce délai si
le gouvernement
naturellement est suivi par le parlement
dans cette affaire mettre à profit ce
délai pour adapter la loi et lui
permettre de remplir son véritable rôle
c'est-à-dire de permettra à marchés
financiers actifs exister en france
la préoccupation essentielle est donc
dans cette affaire celle de l'emploi la
santé de la bourse pour le premier
ministe et pour le président conditionne
la santé de l'emploi de son marché le
président de la république a rappelé son
désir qu'il existe en france un marché
financier actif et je répète n'est ce
pas pour une raison tout à fait clair
c'est que l'emploi est quelque chose qui
en france actuellement préoccupe tous
les français qui préoccupe le
gouvernement et qu' il n'y a pas
d'emploi sans investissements et donc
sans un marché financier actif
le projet avait été évoqué au cours de
la campagne présidentielle de 74
l'idée générale était de moderniser un
système fiscal disparate avec par
exemple l'explosion de l'immobilier il
paraît juste de taxer les plus values
qui constitue un revenu supplémentaire
un premier texte le rapport mon bilan
est établi monsieur pierre uhry est
ensuite chargé de faire un autre rapport
il faut attendre une levée de boucliers
dit-il lui-même avant la discussion de
son texte adopté de justesse 5,75 par le
comité économique et social
le 1er juin 76 donc un long débat
s'engage devant l'assemblée nationale
il provoque le dépôt d'une pluie
l'amendement le projet se heurte entre
autres à l'hostilité du dr et met à
l'épreuve la cohésion de la majorité
on a enfin l'impression de faire de la
politique dit monsieur gino la bataille
des plus values devient la fronde de
l'ue dr monsieur fourcade fait le compte
des partisans de son texte sur les bancs
de l'assemblée n'y trouve qu'un
enthousiaste jean jacques servan
shreiber
malgré ce solo l'action du gouvernement
et du chef de l'état se trouve bloquée
par le groupe principal de la majorité
parlementaire
le débat qui devait durer huit jours
s'éternise
monsieur giscard d'estaing chacun le
sait s'est engagé personnellement à
propos des plus values les députés qui
n'approuverons pas le projet at il dit
en avril ne pourront plus se prévaloir
de l'action réformatrice du président de
la république monsieur chirac premier
ministre prend alors la parole devant
les députés il faut voter sans tarder un
texte désormais tout à fait convenable
ces faits le 23 juin au début du mois de
juillet 76 le sénat examine à son tour
le projet et le 10 juillet le texte
qu'on n'ose plus qualifiés de
gouvernementales tentent ils aient été
modifiées est adoptée définitivement par
le parlement
on s'en félicite à l'elysée le chef de
l'état déclare la session a montré que
non seulement il n'y avait pas une crise
mais que gouvernement au contraire
c'était montrer persuasif bien alors il
faut peut-être tenté une explication
noël copains d'abord la question bien
sûr qui a pris l'initiative le premier
ministre ou président la république n'y
a quand une décision de cette nature là
est prise par le conseil des ministres
on peut dire qu'il s'agit d'une décision
conjointe du président de la république
du premier ministre et de l'ensemble du
gouvernement
mais dans la mesure où cette décision
comme vous l'avez dit vous-même tout à
l'air était une surprise on l'attribué
cet après midi à monsieur bart je dirais
simplement que si le premier ministre a
eu à convaincre le président de la
république
celui ci s'est peut-être laissé d'autant
plus facilement convaincre qu'il a eus
ces jours ci des conversations et des
représentants des petites et moyennes
entreprises et qu'au cours de ces
conversations était beaucoup question
d'investissements et de confiance
donc la loi sur les plus values
mobilières reporté au 1er janvier 1979
c'est à dire après les législatives
on serait tenté d'y voir bien sûr des
motivations politiques bien c'est
sûrement par nature même
un acte politique c'est un acte
politique si l'on se réfère d'ailleurs
ce qui s'est passé l'année dernière et
que nous venons d'évoquer
il est certain que monsieur bart n'a pas
craint d'affronter les sourires et les
critiques aussi bien du rpr que
d'opposition mais c'est surtout un acte
politique en fonction d'une situation
présente
si vous permettez je crois qu'il faut
souligner une phrase est un mot
important dans le communiqué du conseil
des ministres
l'application des dispositions de la loi
relative aux plus values mobilières
n'est pas opportune elle n'est pas
opportune on l'a dit pour des raisons
techniques les décrets d'application les
textes d'application sont longs et
difficiles à rédiger et on veut bien le
croire et ça nécessitait un report mais
c'est surtout pour des raisons
politiques et économiques qu'elle est
inopportune
elle est inopportune en fonction de la
situation de la bourse monsieur bart a
voulu donner un coup de fouet à ses à
cette bourse recréer la confiance parmi
ceux qui investissent et un acte
psychologique pour redonner la confiance
c'est bien par nature un acte politique
est un acte qui s'inscrit dans une
politique d'ensemble qui est la
politique de l'emploi comme monsieur le
cas nous le signaler tout à l'heure on a
un peu l'impression d'ailleurs que le
premier ministre en ce moment veut
reprend l'initiative c'est le cas nous
le verrons aussi tout à l'heure à propos
de la sidérurgie
oui tout à l'air au milieu du débat
d'idées questions d'actualité le premier
ministre ayant à faire face et non
seulement critiques de l'opposition mais
aussi aux inquiétudes exprimées parfois
avec vivacité et de membres de la
majorité sur le problème de la
sidérurgie a annoncé qu' il y aurait un
débat à l'assemblée nationale sur ce
sujet avant même que s'ouvre le débat à
la fin de ce mois sur le plan d'action
gouvernemental alors en tout cas
philippe sassier l'annoncent donc de ce
report du projet sur les plus values
nous lisions était très très bien
accueillie à la bourse on peut même
parler d'une véritable faurie on peut
parler d'euphorie pour reprendre le
titre d'un film célèbre c'était jour de
fête aujourd'hui à la bourse de paris en
début de séance ont baissé de 1% c'est
une ambiance de veillée mortuaire comme
souvent depuis quelques jours et puis
lors d'un seul coup dès qu'on a appris
cette nouvelle
pour ce il souhaité citer on disait
c'est vrai ce n'est pas vrai si si c'est
officiel est en fait tenu des valeurs
qui ont un seul coût flamber on a monté
le 12 % et en moyenne la bourse depuis
le début séance a monté de 5% donc
vraiment on peut parler d'euphorie
depuis les municipales savait que la
bourse se portait très très mal elle
avait fortement baissé la et fortement
plongé et quant à ce projet sur les plus
values et bien il avait fait baisser la
bourse de plus de 17% en 1976 pour te
lèves et tu es très édulcoré dans
beaucoup de pays et bien il est une
taxation sur les plus values mobilières
dans cette décision cette du premier
ministre et du président de la
république il faut voir plusieurs
raisons d'abord une raison logique
ministre est trop la république veut le
mettre en harmonie leurs paroles avec
leurs actes monsieur vrai lombard a
déclaré dernièrement que la bourse était
un mécanisme important délai de prouver
qu effectivement il estime que la bourse
est avec alice maintenant puisque il
repousse d'un an le projet n'est pas
abandonné l europe plus d'un an
l'application de ce projet est furieux
est ce que cela suffira à relancer les
investissements non ça ne suffira
seulement pas relancé avec les
investissements la bourse représentent
environ 10% des investissements d un des
industries les cénacles psychologique
extrêmement important car raymond barre
de montrer ainsi qu'il croit à une
reprise de l'économie il ne veut pas que
tout soit bloqué parle
la perspective d'élections législatives
de 1978 alors cet acte de foi en quelque
sorte dans la relance de l'économie et
pour les investissements intervient
juste avant le lancement de l'emprunt de
2 milliards pour les pme lancement qui
doit se faire le 18 avril prochain avant
les grands plans de rustres acte heureux
de restructuration industrielle que vous
connaissez le papier les engrais le plan
sauvetage de la sidérurgie et comme pour
raymond barre investissements rime avec
emploi et bien là on peut peut-être
penser que ce ce pc pkra thon rouge r d
soit heures peut servir effectivement de
détonateurs et restaurer la confiance et
pour raymond barre c'est très important
ça c'est un acte politique important
raymond barre veut rester confiant dans
les investissements et de l'économie
concernant le copain on rejoint là les
propos que tenait hier valéry giscard
d'estaing
les français en ont assez de la
politique politicienne il faut
s'attaquer aux vrais problèmes
oui il s'agit sûrement là de vrais
problèmes les investissements l'emploi
mais ces problèmes-là leurs solutions
sont aussi est de nature politique et
puis ça n'est pas non plus sans
incidence sur le plan électoral
rappelons nous que monsieur bart à la
fois la fonction de mener l'action du
gouvernement mais également de mener la
majorité à la bataille des législatives
et qui l'a souvent dit que la meilleure
façon d'assurer son succès et c'était
l'action du gouvernement et en
particulier le redressement économique
mais c'est peut être aussi d'ailleurs
dans cette perspective que sera revue et
corrigée la trop fameuse taxe
professionnelle qui avait été préparé un
peu hâtivement et qui vous savez a fait
grincer pas mal de dents
je vous donne encore cette information
qui pour l'instant n'est qu'une rumeur
en provenance d'allemagne fédérale
michel poniatowski serait nommé
ambassadeur de france à bonn l'ancien
ministre d'état et ami personnel du
président de la république ne commande
pas l'elysée non plus si la demande
d'agrément tout cas été présenté au
chancelier schmidt
mais il est probable qu'elle serait
accepter des mesures concrètes nous en
parler on un instant il y en a eu
d'autres conseil des ministres les
fonctionnaires seront augmentés de 1 5%
à compter du 1er avril une nouvelle
augmentation est prévue par ailleurs le
1er juin et non pas le 1er juillet comme
cela était prévu initialement afin bien
sûr de réajuster à ce moment là les
salaires en fonction de la hausse des
prix problème concret encore avec cette
fois la politique de la famille les
trois projets de loi feront partie du
plan d'action de 12 mois dont le
parlement devra discuter à partir du 26
avril
et parmi eux bien sûr le complément
familial le complément familial est une
prestation nouvelle qui doit se
substituer aux cinq allocation actuelle
versée sous conditions de ressources
ces allocations sont celles du salaire
unique de la mère au foyer et des frais
de garde
le complément remplacera donc ces
allocations ce qui constitue une
simplification importante
outre cet avantage il concernera un plus
grand nombre de familles puisque le
plafond de ressources sera relevé
deux tiers des familles ayant un enfant
de moins de 3 ans ou au moins trois
enfants bénéficieront de cette réforme
les autres ne perdront rien cette
prestation est destiné à augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat des plus démunis enfin
elle sera distribuée de la même façon
aux familles que la femme travaille ou
non il s'agit donc d'un substitut de
salaire pour les femmes au foyer et
d'une aide pour les mères qui ont une
activité professionnelle
pour elle ce complément compensera
partiellement les frais de la garde de
l'enfant
coût de cette réforme plusieurs
milliards de francs 2 millions 500 mille
familles concernées mais cette mesure
dont le souci de clarification est
évident permettra-t-elle aux femmes de
choisir entre le maintien au foyer et la
poursuite de l'activité professionnelle
certainement pas le complément familial
n'est pas la liberté de choix il ne
résoudra pas tous les problèmes
de nombreuses familles même relativement
aisé avait déclaré simone veil en
décembre 1975 rencontre aujourd'hui des
difficultés qu'une majoration des
prestations ne saurait résoudre comme
l'aménagement des horaires de travail ou
l'humanisation du cadre de vie et le
ministre de la santé de conclure que la
politique familiale ne doit plus être
exclusivement une politique de
prestations nous le disions tout à
l'heure le premier ministre a décidé
également d'engager au parlement le
débat sur la sidérurgie pour expliquer
ce qui a été fait et ce qui sera fait
raymond barre l'a confirmé lui-même
d'ailleurs aux parlementaires cet
après-midi en réponse au député
communiste et à plusieurs représentants
de la majorité
vous avez déclaré hier l'application du
programme commun où ils auraient aussi
mois vingt ans d'efforts et c'est vrai
mais en ce moment où la haine sans le
programme commun on est en train de
ruiner un siècle d'efforts
le gouvernement est prêt à exposer
assemblée nationale la situation dans
laquelle se trouve la sidérurgie les
raisons pour lesquelles un plan de
réorganisation de notre industrie
sidérurgique a été adopté quels ont été
les initiatives prises sur le plan
européen pour la première fois pour
qu'une organisation du marché
communautaire puisse intervenir
quelles sont les actions internationales
qui ont été menées notamment à l'égard
du japon et plus particulièrement
quelles sont les mesures internes qui
sont prises pour que la lorraine
puissent bénéficier d'implantation
industrielle qui permettent à cette
région d'avoir des emplois qui ne soit
ni artificiels ni précaire intervention
était animée à l'assaut mais vous l'avez
constaté tant du côté de l'opposition
d'ailleurs que de la majorité à
thionville c'est la mobilisation jacques
ferry le dit c'est ici même hier soir à
antenne 2 il s'agira par la négociation
de limiter les licenciements que
connaissent déjà beaucoup d'ouvriers
vous avez quel âge 18 ans
cet apprenti à usinor
depuis combien de temps ça fait deux ans
je termine ma deuxième année
vous gagnez combien par mois en moyenne
150 mines serez vous employez par usine
à l'année prochaine
d'après ce que je vois maintenant je
crois quoi vous avez des parents pour
vous et des personnes qui travaillent là
je suis rentré là on m'a dit que c'est
écrit noir sur blanc que je serai
employés à sollac et il ya deux semaines
à la fée gré parce qu'on a plus leur
place en dehors en arrière
avez vous la possibilité de retrouver du
travail dans la région ce qui est prête
à partir éventuellement non alors
qu'allez vous faire ses lacets s'il faut
partir on partira mais
je travaille au service laminoir qui est
le service qui qui va disparaître
complètement
alors vous êtes d'accord pour partir
producteurs du moment pourquoi
absolument pas j'ai toute ma famille ici
je suis moi-même au train de construire
et j'ai deux enfants absolument pas
changé de région qui ont ville métropole
du fer depuis un siècle est désormais la
capitale de crise de la sidérurgie
lorraine
quinze mille emplois sont condamnés dans
la région d'ici 1980 mais le premier
verdict est tombé ici devant les hauts
fourneaux d'usinor plus de 3000 emplois
supprimés dès cette année dont 1000
licenciements
le premier coup de gong du plan de
restructuration de la sidérurgie a sonné
avant même la mise au point définitive
de ces volets sociaux et financiers
les syndicats parlent de sabotage et le
nouveau maire communiste de thionville
accuse on cherche à nous faire part ça
nous faire croire que il y a une part de
la fatalité de la conjoncture
internationale
ce n'est pas la faute aux arabes c'est
tout juste en fait en fait il est
évident qu'il y a une responsabilité
conjointe du grand patronat et du
gouvernement qui a injecté par milliard
par dizaines de milliards de l'argent
dans la sidérurgie et aujourd'hui cet
argent on ne sait même pas où il est
passé
oui où est passé l'argent répète les
thionvillois
il y a dix mois à peine usinor leur
avait annoncé la construction d'une
nouvelle aciérie et l'état avait apporté
120 millions à la cagnotte
or aujourd'hui l'abandon de ce projet
qu'on donne à la mort lente
une ville de 45000 habitants ou 60 % des
demandeurs d'emploi aux moins de 25 ans
car pour un emploi qui meurt dans la
sidérurgie ce sont trois autres qui sont
menacés dans les entreprises de sous
traitance notamment comme celle des
frères en caisse qui depuis 30 ans
travaille pour la sidérurgie dans notre
activité nous avons des conséquences
relativement aux graves en ce sens que
étant situé à 1 500 mètres d'usinor
thionville une commande assez importante
nous a été supprimé c'est une commande
qui représentait quand même de cinq à
six mois de travail et ça fait jamais
plaisir lorsqu'on on se voit avec une
commande supprimés d'un autre côté nous
allons été amenés à pratiquer un
licenciement de huit personnes qui n'est
pas très encourageant en plus et la
sidérurgie représente pour nous tout de
même une
une locomotive qui qui nous pour
laquelle nous sommes un fournisseur et
c'est quand même un impact important
pour nous mais les patrons des petites
entreprises ne sont pas seuls atouts
cadre le chômage partiel qui sévit dans
la sidérurgie ont put déjà certains
solaire ne l'équivalent de neuf jours de
travail par mois une baisse importante
du pouvoir d'achat qui à son tour menace
l'avenir des commerçants de thionville
j'ai le même mode inquiet pour les
conséquences des suppressions d'emplois
très très inquiet parce que nous avons
construit un hypermarché ya cinq ans sur
thionville et il s'est construit
beaucoup de logements autour et nous
sommes très inquiet maintenant pour
l'avenir de cet hypermarché et pour le
commerce thionvillois alors qu'ils ont
winne sera t-elle la première ville
sidérurgiste leur haine à mourir ici un
cinquième de la population est déjà son
travail et si la situation continue de
pourrir
tous les éléments sont désormais réunies
pour que l'indignation succèdent bien vu
la colère dans le contexte social actuel
la crise de la sidérurgie est évidemment
un point de focalisation mais ce n'est
pas le seul à l'appel de la cgt par
exemple conflit des dockers va se
transformer vendredi et samedi en une
greffe totale
et puis la veille demain donc georges
séguy edmond maire doivent se rencontrer
pour essayer de dégager une véritable
unité d'action en commençant peut-être
par la négociation dans le secteur
public et nationalisé alors c'est un peu
patrick la tête comme si tous les
éléments étaient réunis pour une sorte
de printemps social
belhout esquerré aujourd'hui c'est que
nous sommes en 77 et que les rapports
entre le gouvernement et les syndicats
ne vont pas s'améliorer
les syndicats tous les syndicats la cgt
et la cfdt bien sûr mais également force
ouvrière et la cgc
vous le savez s'est donné comme priorité
la lutte contre l'inflation
avec ses conséquences ce que le
gouvernement appelle une progression
limitée des salaires est ce que les
syndicats appellent une diminution du
pouvoir d'achat ajouté à cela une
formation continue en ce moment du
chômage et vous comprendrez que
l'ensemble du secteur social est en
ébullition les conflits déjà très
nombreux durant le premier trimestre se
sont nettement multipliés depuis les
élections municipales au lait comptent
aujourd'hui par centaines et touchent
pratiquement tous les secteurs de
l'économie
c'est ce que les syndicats appellent une
grande combativité de la base il est de
l'intérêt des syndicats de faire monter
la passion sa cianas nord à la
législative et bien c'est justement là
le problème et les syndicats se trouve
paradoxalement dans une situation très
délicate au lendemain de la victoire de
la gauche aux élections municipales il
ya quelques mois seulement des élections
législatives est un secret pour personne
en effet que la gauche là c'est l'été et
la cgt notamment souhaitent la victoire
de la gauche aux prochaines élections
législatives alors donnons labouheyre
social que peuvent-ils faire georges
séguy et nos mères se retrouvent demain
ils vont établir
une bataille qui va devoir éviter deux
grands écueils le pas mary kay c'est une
france paralysée par la grève secouée
par les manifestations et les
occupations d'usinés cet impôt la
psychose mai 68 qui pourrait être
désagréablement seulement qu'on puisse
dire influence est tout de même les
électeurs
jean resseguie et une mère doivent donc
choisir d'éviter la guerre totale pour
faire sauter le verrou du plan barre ils
vont devoir manier plutôt là tu as pensé
hier que kg de dynamite
c'est cela veut dire donc des journées
d'action peut-être national plutôt
secteur par secteur
il s'agira en tout cas pour éviter
certaines ont la grève générale on sait
comment ces gueules générale comment ça
c'est comment elle se termine c'est
souvent beaucoup plus difficile alors
cette stratégie présente tout de même un
deuxième écueil et c'est l'écueil que le
vin vite effectivement ces syndicats il
risque d'être débat n'est par la base et
notamment par les jeunes qui
s'entraînent en prêt actuellement être
sans emploi
certains conflits également comme celui
du sida ou celui des dockers pourrait
bien faire également tâche du sellal a
connu des jours et des semaines qui
viennent on change c'est guillet demeure
en tout cas la marge de manoeuvre est
très étroite en ce moment ils doivent
savoir aller suffisant la loi sans aller
trop loin
c'est finalement beaucoup plus facile à
dire qu'à faire on constate que les
parties au lendemain des municipales
crois nécessaire aux aussi de ramener le
débat politique sur le vrai terrain qui
est celui de l'économique et du social
un exemple parmi tant d'autres
l'aéronautique dans la majorité comme
dans l'opposition on s'inquiète de voir
éventuellement des boeing 737 remplacer
les caravelles affaires de rentabilité
pour faire face mais aussi menaces pôle
emploi l'objet de tout ce remue-ménage
le voici
le boeing 737 ne solde pas aux couleurs
d'air france
et s'il n'appartient pas la compagnie
nationale est en location
déjà symbole ou prélude il remplace les
caravelles sur la ligne des antilles car
il faut les remplacer ces caravelle
anciennes et me débrouillant et surtout
grosses consommatrices de carburant et
ce n'est pas en mettant des moteurs
neufs achetés très cher aux américains
qu'on donnera une nouvelle jeunesse au
caramel
seuls des politiciens peu au courant des
problèmes de l'aéronautique proposer ce
genre de solution qui ne fournira que
très peu de travail aux industries
françaises
mais pourquoi acheter à 737 de chez bree
il ya quelques mois les milieux
spécialisés parlait d'un remplacement
des caravelles par des décennies de chez
douglas comme celui ci à l'époque on
croyait dur comme fer que douglas nous
aiderait à conquérir l'énorme marché
américain avec le super mercure de
dassault et de l'aérospatiale
aujourd'hui on y croit moins beaucoup
moins
est ce que cela veut dire que la
coopération avec de glace est abandonnée
et que l'aérospatiale la remplace par
une collaboration avec boeing
c'est possible surtout que celle ci
existe déjà pour le jumbo jet mais de
façon très réduite
alors imaginons qu air france soit
autorisé à acheter de nouveaux avions de
façon à remplir les carnets de commandes
de l'industrie française d'abord le
gouvernement décidera de commander des
airbus franco allemand comme ceux-ci
parquet à toulouse et attendant les
clients éventuels
ils sont tous blancs sans marque
prêt à transporter leurs clients prêts à
prendre l'air à n'importe quel moment
mais personne n'en veut aujourd'hui d'où
crise dans l'industrie aéronautique
mécontentement menace de licenciement
sir france prend des airbus
supplémentaires tout peut s'arranger de
9 actuellement air france doit passer à
30 d'ici dix ans peut-être faudra-t-il
d'ailleurs accéléré ce rythme la
situation en se détendant un peu
permettra la combinaison suivante après
l'airbus air france commande des boeing
737 selon la technique du buy back des
amériques
cela veut dire qu elle les achète pour
six ans avec garantie de revente aux
constructeurs passé ce délai en quelques
centaines france 10 à l'aérospatiale
vous avez six ans pour me proposer un
avion 200 places qui remplacera et les
caravelles et les boeing 737
en attendant je vous permets par cet
achat chez boeing d'obtenir du travail
grâce à une collaboration avec le
constructeur d'avions américains pour la
fabrication de partis d'avion comme les
ailes
ce scénario est il trop beau pour être
possible c'est ce que l'avenir nous dira
faut-il ou ne faut-il pas vacciner les
enfants la question reste posée à la
veille de la journée de sensibilisation
qu organise demain le ms à travers le
monde le vaccin antivariolique beaucoup
pensent qu'il est aujourd'hui inutile
chez nous que le vaccin anticholérique
est inefficace
en fait le grand heures c'est peut-être
que les vaccinations ne chante pas
toujours suivies l'importance des
vaccins au niveau mondial n'est plus à
démontrer souvenez vous de la campagne
dramatique de vaccination contre la
méningite au brésil il ya deux ans la
france y fut associé de très près
pour la fourniture des doses en ce qui
concerne les enfants chaque année il en
est 80 millions dans le tiers-monde à
peine 4 millions sont vaccinés au moins
5 millions meurent faute de vax en
revanche des maladies disparaissent de
notre globe
par exemple la variole n'existe
pratiquement plus en dehors d'une région
isolée de l'ethiopie de nombreux pays
ont d'ailleurs abandonné l'idée de la
vaccination antivariolique obligatoire
et l'an prochain
il est probable que la france fera de
même dans notre pays le principal
problème c'est celui de la revaccination
en prenant comme exemple tétanos
les médecins constatent que les hommes
sont moins touchés que les femmes ce
sont en fait les vaccinations du service
militaire qui font cette différence car
un vaccin en général ne reste actif que
pendant dix ans il faut donc revacciner
régulièrement l'industrie pharmaceutique
française est très intéressée à cette
campagne mondiale pasteur et meirieu
sont les deux instituts mondialement
connue dans le domaine des vaccins
et certains en france voudrait les voir
fusionner d'autres affaires maintenir
une certaine concurrence
une chose est sûre les vaccins ont
encore de beaux jours devant eux
le temps est toujours frais il faisait
ce matin heure - de annoncer à
strasbourg 0 à roy est déjà dans de
nombreuses régions les agriculteurs font
le décompte des méfaits de ces gelées
que ce soit dans l'autre que ce soit en
bretagne ou dans l'est de la france
jusqu'à 100 % de perte à certains
endroits destruction totale n'est colza
sont grillés mais colza baisse de la
tête 10e ce soir la plupart des
agriculteurs lorrains le vent de la
semaine passée le dernier
conte anéanti cette production
céréalière de plus en plus ici on s'aime
du colza destination les coopératives
pourront faire de l'huile principalement
de colza fourrager dans la région il a
été épargnés de toute façon dans la
commune de dieulouard c'est un exemple
les vents dominants ont appuyé le colza
en plaine il a gelé en hauteur résultat
à 800 francs à l'hectare de pertes
sèches déjà les agriculteurs en semences
à nouveau une calamité de plus pas de
change au nhs partout c'est le gris qui
domine signe infaillible de jeu les
récentes côté arbres fruitiers
heureusement la mirabelle fierté
lorraine
la mirabelle c'est l'olive de la
provence n'est pas trop touché 20 à 30%
tout de même de faire temps plein
rien sur les coteaux cerise précoce 90 à
100% du dga c'est considérable et
framboise et groseille sont touchés à 60
% estime le comité fruits et légumes de
l'est
déjà l'an dernier pourtant les petits
fruits avaient beaucoup souffert
reste les frêles de woippy une
importante production à côté de metz et
des gars vont de 40 à 65 % selon les
zones et le degré de pessimisme une
augmentation de plus pour cause de gel
cette fois à la peine de l'actualité
sportive pour en gagner résultats cet
après midi oui dans la première
demi-finale des matches aller de la
coupe d'europe des clubs champions à
kiev kiev a battu mönchengladbach à 0 1
but de onichtchenko à la 71e minute
je rappelle que vous verrez dans la
dernière édition du journal d'antenne ou
les buts de l'autre demi finale
zurich liverpool et puis vous avez un
rendez-vous auparavant ce soir sur
antenne 2 toujours ou bien sûr vous
resterez rendez vous avec l'information
jean pierre elkabbach puisque à partir
de 21h30 débute le nouveau magazine
question de temps vas-y de la formation
il ya quelques semaines je vous avais
promis à partir du début du mois d'avril
un rendez vous hebdomadaire avec
l'actualité et bien
depuis la promesse sera tenue avec
question de temps un nouveau titre pour
un nouveau magazine chaque semaine le
mercredi soir la rédaction d'antenne 2
essaiera en 1h30 d'aller plus loin de
montrer de mieux faire comprendre et
d'expliquer l'actualité nos équipes
sillonnent déjà la france parcourt le
monde pour vous rapporter des images
vraies et sans fard nous l'appelons
question de temps car les actes les
décisions les mouvements qui agit sur
notre vie quotidienne ont une histoire
un passé et il annonce déjà autre chose
un avenir question tant chaque semaine
avec une formule souple des gens et des
titres différents par exemple cartes sur
table
on est vite et seul en direct face à des
journalistes alain duhamel que vous
connaissez et moi-même un contre deux
pour faire naître peut-être un peu plus
de vérité premier invité de cartes sur
table ou l'annoncent raymond barre
premier ministre le 20 avril à 20 heures
le 27 avril pierre dreyfus qui était
pendant de nombreuses années
le patron de renault nos 25 mai georges
marchais mercredi prochain un grand
témoignage de roger pic paul nahon et
daniel mailhot qui sont interrogés entre
hanoi et saigon sur le prix de la paix
au vietnam
et dès ce soir premier de ces rendez
vous pour un question temps animé tout à
l'heure par louis blériot miracle aux
philippines
un film réalisé par jean luc magneron
pour antenne de jeu proxy d'un document
dur bouleversante courageux
après plusieurs semaines aux philippines
en compagnie des plus célèbres
guérisseur jean luc vigneron rapporte un
document choc sur la chirurgie à mains
nues
vos proches avaient l'intention de faire
le voyage
ne manquez pas ce film bouleversant
notamment cependant avertir les
personnes sensibles de la violence de
certaines images aux philippines
mercredi 6 avril à 21h25
par conséquent tout à l'heure et
j'espère qu assez vite
vous ne regrettez pas de fidèles à
question de temps réalisé par la
rédaction d'antenne 2 et puis bien sûr
je vous rappelle le dernier rendez vous
d'information de la soirée vers 23
heures avec gérard holtz
bonsoir